y yo empecé mi carrera en educación como
maestra de preescolar y la primera vez
que tuve un grupo de niños y niñas a mi
cargo había un pequeñito de tres años
que cuando se emocionaba mucho con algo
que aprendía me decía en todo lo que
tengo de vida nunca he visto nada igual
y miren me llegó el momento a mí de
decir que en todo lo que tengo de vida
nunca había vivido una experiencia tan
extraordinaria como la que estamos
viviendo en el mundo en este momento y
aunque tengo experiencia en ofrecer
conferencias y dar clases por muchos
años nunca me había enfrentado a un
público tan numeroso como el día de hoy
y quería compartir con ustedes mi idea
de que me parece que la educación
siempre ha debido hacer pero ahora en
este momento con más razón debería ser
sin distancia y les voy a explicar a qué
me refiero creo que hay que acortar las
distancias geográficas o sociales y
sociales creo que hay que acortar la
distancia cognitiva y que hay que
acortar la distancia afectiva esto lo
que significa es dar más énfasis al
aprendizaje y más responsabilidad a la
pendiente sobre su propio proceso
qué quiero decir con sin distancia
geográfica o social
esto para poder acortar la distancia
geográfica o social en educación se
necesita una decisión política una
decisión política muy firme porque tiene
implicaciones de ducati económicas muy
grandes sin el papel mi maestro que ya
paulo mencionó
desde los años 1970 o por ahí estaba
pensando en esta idea de cómo acortar la
distancia geográfica y la distancia
social en educación y el diseño junto
con alan kay una especie de tableta muy
liviana portátil para que fuera
programada por los niños y las niñas
piensen que en aquel momento las
computadoras estaban metidas en unos
cuartos enormes incluso con aire
acondicionado y solamente podría ser
programada por expertos y expertas de
hecho había muchas programadoras y en
aquel momento simon estaba hablando de
una tableta un dispositivo que era móvil
liviano para que los niños y las niñas
lo programarán por supuesto que no le
hicieron caso
a finales del siglo y principios de este
milenio simón siguió con su idea y
propuso que se diera una computadora por
estudiante lo que se llamó el proyecto o
el epc por sus siglas en inglés en
algunos de los países de ustedes en
algunas regiones de nuestros países
estamos haciendo ese esfuerzo de llevar
una computadora por estudiante pero no
ha sido una decisión política no ha sido
una inversión económica enorme como la
que se requiere porque además no sólo se
requiere el dispositivo se requiere la
conexión a internet de alta velocidad
pero claro acortar las distancias
geográficas y sociales no es suficiente
porque no es cuestión de entregar
computadoras tecnología digital
dispositivos y dar buena conexión a
internet aunque eso es difícil y caro y
además si lo hacemos no es suficiente
por eso simón también
mucho en cómo es que debemos usar esta
tecnología digital
sin distancia cognitiva a quien nos
referimos con eso a qué me refiero con
eso a quien no solamente es suficiente
darle las tecnologías a los estudiantes
a los aprenden test la conexión a
internet y tener los contenidos que
necesitamos para que aprendan sino que
hay que tomar varias acciones por
ejemplo la edad no es lo mismo como
aprende mi alumno de cuatro años de tres
años
como aprendo yo o como aprenden mis
estudiantes en la universidad y hay
muchos autores que ya han hablado de las
diferentes formas en que aprendemos de
acuerdo con la edad entonces la misma
forma que yo voy a tener para usar con
tecnología digital para unas poblaciones
no es la misma que puedo usar con otras
entonces la edad es algo que yo tengo
que tomar mucho en consideración ya hay
autores que han dicho cómo se hace
incluso lo hacemos aunque sea en el aula
física con más razón en un entorno
virtual también hay que tomar en cuenta
la disciplina el contenido el concepto
la materia no se aprende igual el
concepto o la materia si es proveniente
de la física o la matemática que si es
del arte o el derecho también los
autores especialistas en didáctica nos
han dicho cómo se aborda las diferentes
eso también hay que consultarlo no es
simplemente dar la computadora y él
en la conexión a internet sino que hay
que hacer muy claramente un diseño de
actividades que sean adecuadas para lo
que estamos queriendo que nuestros
aprendiendo puedan ir construyendo otra
cosa muy importante es el aprendizaje
colaborativo hay muchos autores que nos
han dicho que el aprendizaje es una un
proceso social me viene a la mente en
este momento le digo aquí que ha hablado
del aprendizaje social
yo puedo aprender muchas cosas yo solita
pero si no lo comparto si no lo hago
público si no lo conversó con otras
personas no lo voy a aprender muy
profundamente ni voy a saber hasta qué
nivel lo comprendo y que me queda por
aprender sobre un concepto o una materia
o una disciplina
el aprendizaje colaborativo es algo que
es muy importante que podamos promover
actividades de aprendizaje colaborativo
independientemente de la edad muchas de
las recomendaciones que voy a estar
dando aquí son independientemente de la
edad
aunque hay que tomar en cuenta qué edad
tienen las personas los niños las niñas
los jóvenes o los adultos
una técnica didáctica que se usa mucho
actualmente incluso no necesariamente en
entornos virtuales pero que si vamos a
ir entornos virtuales es conveniente que
llevemos
el aprendizaje inverso qué quiere decir
eso por cientos de años en educación
hemos estado acostumbrados a que la
persona que sabe se para adelante de una
clase y entrega la información y luego
los estudiantes las estudiantes se van
para sus casas con las dudas con las
preguntas con no saber si si lo
entendieron o no lo entendieron bien
la clase inversa del aprendizaje inverso
es hacerlo al revés nos reunimos y les
damos un reto una lectura
y una tarea un proyecto para hacer y el
estudiantado lo hace lo lee lo investiga
y cuando nos volvemos a reunir entonces
entre todos de manera colaborativa
podemos responder las preguntas y ver
qué dudas quedan o de qué manera podemos
entender todos estos conceptos
la investigación y la indagación son
procesos que son de la vida diaria de
quienes se dedican a la investigación
para crear nuevos conocimientos para la
humanidad pero es muy importante en este
momento eso es lo que queremos que la
indagación sobre todo sea parte de la
didáctica que sea parte del aprendizaje
cuando decimos que el estudiantado tome
control de su propio aprendizaje estamos
diciendo en parte que haga una
investigación una indagación que busque
en el mundo y que luego entre todos
podemos socializar y convertir esa
información que hemos buscado y
encontrado en conocimiento
una de las formas más importantes para
aprender es la conversación el diálogo
hay un biólogo chileno muy importante
muy reconocido que se llama humberto
maturana que incluyó incluso acuñó un
término el habla del lenguaje ar
dice somos humanos en tanto nos
comunicamos por medio del lenguaje
somos humanos en tanto lenguaje hemos
entonces la parte de diálogo de la
comunicación de la colaboración mediante
el diálogo es muy importante en la
educación en el aprendizaje y eso
incluye el uso de tecnologías digitales
o el uso de plataformas virtuales para
el aprendizaje
sin distancia cognitiva significa
entonces en que debe estar centrado en
el aprendiz ente
si yo voy a diseñar una actividad en el
entorno virtual o en el entorno físico
para mis estudiantes y digo que voy a
que espero yo que mis estudiantes hagan
para aprender y si la respuesta que
tengo es lo que necesito es que escuchen
y vean y respondan
no estamos haciendo bien la tarea de
acompañar el aprendizaje lo que
necesitamos es diseñar actividades en la
que los
aprenden test exploren
creen
diseñen
investiguen indaguen
propongan
construyan programen colaboren
y todo esto estas acciones que queremos
de una pendiente que es activo y dueño
de su propio aprendizaje centrado en el
aprendizaje sin distancia cognitiva
tiene un nombre en educación y muchos de
ustedes lo están usando en las aulas
tradicionales físicas bueno eso hay que
llevarlo cuando usted acá hacemos uso de
tecnologías digitales o cuando hacemos
uso de un entorno virtual se llama un
aprendizaje basado en proyectos y es más
o menos lo que les viene explicando
anteriormente
de cómo hacemos para que el aprendizaje
no tenga una distancia cognitiva
y finalmente sin distancia afectiva
muchos autores nos han dicho que el
aprendizaje en buena medida tiene que
ver con la emoción eso lo menciono
hernán anteriormente también y lo que
significa es que quien acompaña el
aprendizaje tiene que acompañarlo tiene
que estar tiene que hacerse presente aún
en el aula física a veces estamos con el
cuerpo presente pero no tenemos una
conexión afectiva con nuestros
estudiantes y sobre todo en el entorno
virtual o con el uso de tecnologías
digitales es muy importante hacerse
presente y como nos hacemos presentes en
un entorno virtual bueno no es tan
difícil no es tan difícil como por
ejemplo se acuerdan de sheldon cooper en
la serie la teoría del big band quedes
con todo su conocimiento físico y todo
su conocimiento
de computación y de programación diseñó
este robot para hacerse presente en la
universidad del trabajaba
eso sería muy interesante y divertido
pero no es necesario nos podemos hacer
presentes después que nos hayamos
reunido que les hayamos puesto el reto a
los estudiantes por medio de correos
electrónicos los jóvenes y adultos
tenemos correo electrónico y los más
pequeños podemos pedirle a los familias
que tengan un correo electrónico en el
cual yo me voy a estar comunicando con
ellos después que les díaz el reto y que
están tratando de resolverlo los grupos
de whatsapp son muy muy adecuados y son
los más pequeños aunque a los adultos
también nos gustan mensajes de audio o
de vídeo para que sepan que mientras
están respondiendo el reto que mientras
están haciendo la indagación que
mientras están haciendo la tarea estamos
pensando en ellos y les podemos
preguntar cómo les va qué dudas tienen
que necesitan antes de volver a
reunirnos y desarrollar el proyecto los
foros de discusión para lenguaje ar como
dirían maturana
muy importantes en todas las plataformas
de entornos virtuales hay foros de
discusión y hay que aprovecharlos
sin distancia afectiva es muy importante
hay que estar hay que acompañar y
hacerse presente hay una frase que yo
escucho mucho y que en realidad no sé
quién sería el autor o la autora lo
buscado no lo encontrado asumo que es
una frase popular que dice cuando
creíamos tener todas las respuestas
surgieron nuevas preguntas
y yo tengo una pregunta para usted es
cuando la nueva realidad llegue
qué vamos a hacer en educación
vamos a regresar a la educación que
teníamos vamos a retornar a la educación
que teníamos
ya será en el aula física
o lo que habíamos avanzado en el aula
virtual o con el apoyo de tecnologías
digitales
o vamos a aprovechar esta oportunidad
para hacer los cambios que hace mucho
mucho eran necesarios en la educación y
en el aprendizaje
mi voto es por la opción b
y el surf
muchas gracias
[Música]